The Joe Rogan experience,
a lot of people believe it's a
controlled demolition.
I don't think necessarily she is saying
that it is or it isn't and I certainly
am not.
I don't know.
I don't understand that.
You know what I believe more.
It was a controlled demolition.
Yes.
But with it by us.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean I think that's always been the
case of the.
The argument,
they don't think it was done by the
terrorists.
They think see building the tear.
What?
No.
What if the terrorists.
Oh,
they did a controlled demolition.
Yeah.
It wasn't like if somehow they had.
Because terrace probably could easily.
I think that would probably be before
hijacking planes and flying them into
buildings before that would be putting a
bomb into building.
Yes,
but it's not that easy.
See,
like when will you see what happened in
Oklahoma City that was multiple bombs?
You know,
in Oklahoma City they actually,
there was all these reports of the FBI
removing bombs from the building like
that didn't explode.
And if you talk to these guys that are
demolition experts,
they say there's no way.
That was a fertilizer bomb.
There's no fucking way.
They said that.
If you look at the amount of damage that
did and look at where the blast radius
is from the way it blows out,
it doesn't blow.
They're not designed to.
You're saying this building because
we've all seen the loose change where
you watch the lights go off around the
building one floor by one.
It's like,
yeah,
but see they don't see.
They don't know what that means though.
That also could be.
If the ceiling is coming in and slamming
into the floor,
all the windows would do that.
They don't know that that's explosions.
If it really was collapsing like that.
See no one's ever seen a building
collapsed like that.
So when they say that those are blips
and those are squibs,
I don't like that because then you're.
You're saying you know for sure what
that is and I'm saying the fuck you do.
I don't know.
Even though there's just because someone
has to know.
I'm not saying it was as.
I'm not saying it was an inside job.
It just seems odd ergonomically that you
would design a building that if impacted
at a certain point the entire thing
would demolish.
Like what structurally?
What purpose does that serve?
Well,
the.
Yeah,
the weird.
Well,
it could just be in competence.
That's possible.
If you look at humans,
that's our most likely option,
right?
I mean when did they make the world
trade center so fucking long ass time
ago to get so cocky to build a building
that's 100 God damn stories high.
And how long did they think that was
gonna stay up there for you know,
what if it started falling apart in a
rotting,
what it was,
it was just so just a wonky piece of
shit by the time I got hit by those
planes.
That's totally true.
I mean fucking thing was oldest shit.
That thing was around as black and white
television.
Jessica Lange,
King Kong.
I mean.
Yeah,
but what's retrofitting the cheapest
goddamn floor and the cheapest guy.
A bitter,
you know that to do that.
How many floors was treated with bombs
maybe?
Well,
that's the crazy idea.
What we're,
what we're saying about a building seven
or or the other building that terrorists
could have done it.
I mean I guess they could have,
but how the fuck are they going to get
in there and put all those explosives
in?
It's like dynamite up a time.
Those red sticks of dynamite.
One tying up your ass.
You're working the fucking thing.
Five years everyday.
Fucking putting it into this closet.
So funny.
Back then they didn't have security
department sticks.
You're walking down the hallway and you
just smell shit.
Open this door.
What's in this smells like shit and it
says shitty dynamite sticks.
It's like a fucking log house built with
shit dynamite sticks and little hairs.
A Cat pee mattress.